foreign
bring it on
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the halloween edition
of binge battle today it's rotten
tomatoes
versus fandango two esteemed competitors
are gonna be representing each squad
here and that's how you're watching us
right now you're either on the rotten
tomatoes facebook page
or you're on the fandango facebook page
or you might be watching us by movie
clips
on youtube so welcome welcome one and
all we love having your eyeballs and
eardrums focused on
celebrating halloween and the season of
horror movies
and we have some of the all-time great
horror movie critics
fans lovers of the genre here to duke it
out with
at least four different categories yes
if you're familiar with binge battle you
know
we at least go four rounds deep and then
we might have to have a tiebreaker
it's a free-for-all it's a tag team
however you want to classify it
it is going to be the proverbial hoot
and i am so happy to be on board
my name is mark ellis and now it is my
honor to welcome
first up team fandango
and they are represented by the one the
only
managing editor of fandango he is eric
davis everyone eric how are you doing
today
are you feeling ready to battle i'm
feeling ready i have
a good buddy of mine hanging out with me
uh
bringing me lots of lots of good luck
and creepy vibes
and uh i'm ready to roll all right and
your
teammate today is one of my good friends
host producer actor extraordinaire and
you can check her out on the
something scary podcast and on twitter
her current name right now
markia mccarty you want to give us what
your name on twitter is currently for
the season
uh yeah it's marquee
mccarty
i love it and i am so excited to have
you on board it's good to see your face
again i know you're you're local to
where i am in southern california we
were joking with eric about how nice our
weather is so
y'all are by coastal right now but
you're competing on behalf
of fandango so remember everybody if you
want to vote for team
fandango in any of these rounds you the
viewer are going to determine who wins
each round so
you want to vote for team fandango
you're going to be doing that with your
heart you're going to click that heart
button the love button
if you think that markia eric a
combination of the two made the better
argument
in each round but boy do they have a
daunting task ahead of them because over
here on team
rotten tomatoes is in my opinion the
greatest host in the history of movie
talk i
ranked fifth in my own poll she is also
the uh
senior producer at collider and another
one of my dear friends joining us today
perry nemeroff from long island perry
how you doing
every single time you say that it still
gets me you deserve all the credit in
the world i learned from the best
i don't know who you're talking about
but i was just happy to steward the ship
until you were ready to take the reins
um we move on to your teammate now
and i'm so glad i got his intro right
because a lot of times he tells me what
to do and he's always right about it he
is the editor-in-chief of rotten
tomatoes joel mears how you doing buddy
i'm well mark how you doing i am so
excited to hear you
weigh in and to to just get dirty and
get nasty i look forward to the nasty
side of joel
and i think that's going to come out
here is that true yeah i think so i
think you're going to bring it out of me
or maybe eric's going to bring it out of
me uh
you know he's brought some props he
needs some props um
so we'll see how that works out for him
i think yeah eric that uh that that
michael myers mask in the background has
that ever actually been worn by you to
scare trick-or-treat
of course i actually i have i have two
kids and what i like to do is is go
outside their windows with the myers
mask and just kind of lightly knock on
the window
and i traumatized my son for a couple of
weeks after doing that
so yeah it gets a lot of warmth get
through
parenting 101 ladies and gentlemen what
are they doing out there in long island
eric this is crazy yeah it's a crazy
place long island
you get uh a lot of thrills on on either
coast uh trick-or-treat night i'm not
sure how trick-or-treat is gonna go so
everybody just
pop open a reese's cup right now and
enjoy us for about the next hour as we
take you through
the halloween binge battle keep in mind
you are voting for rotten tomatoes
then you're going to be clicking that
button you see it you'll love it
nat you'll like it it's the like button
for rotten tomatoes you see the blue
button
goes to the red team rotten tomatoes and
the red button goes to the blue squad
team fandango you see how they try to
trip me up but i'm not falling for it
not today the blue button is for team
rotten tomatoes
the red button is for team fandango as
soon as you hear a good argument you
like somebody made a good point you want
to wait to hear
everybody's argument is probably the
proper way to do it then vote then the
team's going to tally it up behind the
scenes and let me know who won
each round and then we move on so
i'm going to give it to team rotten
tomatoes first here with this first
category would you all like to go first
or defer to your opponent
do you have any strong feelings joe
now i'm going to defer to you perry to
make this decision so uh what have had
it
i don't know i'm feeling pretty good
about who we have here so i say we go
first
yeah let's do it all right team rotten
tomatoes
is gonna be on the clock so here's how
it's gonna work uh either perry i will
give it to perry is going to have a
minute
to give her argument then we're going to
bounce over to team fandango they'll
elect the team member to go first we'll
go back to joel for a minute we'll go
back to fandango for a minute then we're
going to get some rebuttals
and then we're going to sort out who has
the best argument
in the category of come on we argue
about this all the time
who is the ultimate horror movie
villain ultimate villain in any horror
movie
perry nemeroff a minute on the clock and
go
i understand why someone's knee-jerk
reaction to hearing that question might
be to go with one of the most iconic
looking slashers of all time
but really you could physically defend
yourself
against them you can run from them so i
found myself gravitating towards a
villain
that really seeped in and reflected the
very real horrors that we all deal with
and it's the babadook
the babadook is a character that
literally embodies
your deepest challenges and your demons
and really out there who of all of you
have not tried to bottle up
all your anger and grief and just tuck
it all away
this movie and this character in
particular just proves
that that doesn't work and it could come
back at you in a very dangerous way and
when it bubbles up the babadook gives
you two choices
you could either submit an amelia's case
that means killing her son or you could
fight it by acknowledging that it exists
the thing that makes the babadook
especially eerie and really stick with
me though is that even if you do choose
the latter and you choose to fight it
there's still no getting rid of it the
only solution to the babadook is finding
a way to maintain it and the fact that
all of that negativity is kind of just
baggage that you carry around and
that's that also connects to just the
truth of our existence
is deeply unsettling which is why i
think
the babadook is the ultimate horror
villain all right there's that boxing
bill and that was a sterling minute
presentation
arguing for the babadook well done perry
that's how you kick us off so now we go
over to team
fandango eric marquia who wants to go
first and answer
the bell from perry uh i have a question
uh is it that we are putting forth our
own argument or we're also
countering uh you can feel free to do
whatever you want with your minute i
would recommend putting forth your
argument
in the minute and then for the 30 second
rebuttal that's when you can get into
either joel or perry's or both
characters with 30 seconds but
you got a minute on the clock you might
as well give us your argument first
gotcha all right uh eric
what what are you feeling here my dude i
say you go first
okay great all right marquia we are
gonna put a minute on the clock
and the floor is officially yours
okay so um for me i've chosen
a real life ultimate horror villain you
know something that can't just be
killed with the power of love like it's
a sailor moon episode like
you might have with uh some other
villains that are going to be discussed
and mine is uh the secret government uh
in the us in us so with this i mean this
is just
chilling bone chilling to me because
this is a real life thing
we have governments our own government
other governments that are doing things
now that we have no
idea about we don't know if it's going
to be something like an us with like
this mind control experiment
that fails and then there's this
revolution that happens
with these hapless victims that then
rise up against all of us
and the thing of it is is that in
history itself we've seen this you
cannot
kill this type of evil like for instance
like with like nazi germany
uh whereas like those doctors they they
weren't all held responsible for their
crimes they then
were then hired by other governments in
the world to then continue
their you know where it was like oh
they're
leaps in uh experimentation like this
doesn't go away we only find this stuff
out
decades afterwards and especially now
with like 2020
and everything that we're finding out
with about ourselves and about
government in general
this is absolutely horrifying and i
think this was
so on the nose for jordan peele to do
that it resonates now it resonates
um in the past and it will resonate in
the future
all right mark here right at the minute
mark
and that's elevated to the next level if
you want to get crazy
then we can get crazy as we throw it
back to joel
mears for his greatest horror movie
villain who's the scariest one joel you
got a minute
starting now well i'm going really old
school
and throwing it back to 1960 norman
bates as played by anthony perkins in
psycho
it's the original slasher film he's in
many ways the original slasher
you don't get michael you don't get
jason you don't get ghostface
or randy or whoever it did in that film
um without uh norman bates really doing
it in the beginning
he's psychologically complex he's
unpredictable
he's human which is incredibly scary
because he's not just some sort of
made-up ghost
unstoppable force that again uh sailor
moon can be
sort of get rid of them in the end um
and he delivered
not just some of the most iconic kills
in all of horrordam
obviously the shower but some of the
most in sort of memorable lines
we all go a little crazy we all go a
little mad sometimes
and we think about psycho as the first
film but he actually was such an
interesting character
he carried through to the 80s and some
really actually decent sequels
and then was rich enough to be explored
in base motel which is a really
underrated
and solid tv show so norman bates he's
the king
without him you don't get the others
okay
there's joe coming in just under the gun
and now
all i can think about is did the
government do experiments on the bates
family maybe that's why they went a
little mad sometimes so
great arguments is all we get day in and
day out around this place and eric davis
your opening salvo one minute on the
clock best
horror movie villain ever go yeah he's
sitting right behind me i am going
michael myers i think that there is
nothing scarier
than pure evil you know the kind of evil
that is unstoppable with myers you may
win
the day uh but you are bound to have a
long
multi-sequel battle uh with michael
myers and i just think there's nothing
scarier than
a masked you know psycho roaming around
your
your quaint suburban neighborhood that
can just pop into your house when the
babysitter's over
and and just slash you up with a knife
he's mysterious
we don't know much about him and that's
what's what's great about him
but then we also yearn to know more
about him
you know and i love how he can drive a
car
and get gas and fill that up does he pay
for it we don't know and that's great
that we don't know that
uh but i you know i think he makes a
william shatner mask
uh look the scariest thing of all time
and and shatner's not even a scary guy
so
i think that michael myers um just paved
the way
for slashers you know i don't think
norman bates really did i think it was
myers and that 1978 halloween film
which is uh you know known as as the
best horror movie that's ever been made
and there is a reason why
because it's myers against the greatest
heroine uh ever and laurie strode
um myers hands down more memorable than
your babadook and your norman bates
it's myers that's who you want to dress
up as for halloween
that's whose mask i have behind me
unforgettable
michael myers ultimate horror villain
and now i can't stop thinking about
whether michael myers would
if he pays for gas is he paying cash who
which
what credit card company gave him a line
of credit to his swipe
if he just this is what i'm saying i
want one scene where the guy comes out
to try to get cash from him
for filling up and he's just like you
know butchers them somehow but
it is a question i always wonder he
drives long distances
uh how is he filling that up how does he
film that maybe the next
the next halloween movie so much
headcanon and apparently uh
as soon as we're done here uh we all get
to go check out the new trailer that
just dropped for halloween kills
so in the meantime uh remember the fans
out there watching if you're watching on
either fandango rotten tomatoes facebook
page
you are gonna be the judge as to who's
winning these arguments so we just heard
the opening minute from each competitor
from each team
you're voting with your heart with that
love button if you think fandango
is making the better argument go with
that like button if you think that
rotten tomatoes
is doing better so far and now we move
on to the 30-second rebuttal
starting with perry nemeroff perry 30
seconds on the clock support your
character
go after everybody else's character the
floor is yours for 30 seconds
i'm coming for you first marquia you
can't be the ultimate horror
villain if you are presented as vaguely
as the government is
in us i love the movie but i can't
picture what that villain is really so
i can't go for that and a lot of the
argument was
this could happen this could be the
babadook is
everybody knows what their inner demons
are that is what the babadook is
and as far as joel's argument versus
eric
joel wins that hands down by looking at
the legacy of norman baked whereas as
much as i love the very first halloween
movie that franchise has some
seriously subpar sequels and along the
way
michael's michael myers gets a little
less scary from them so
he kind of pales in comparison now okay
perry throwing fire at
everybody there marquia 30 second
rebuttal to use however you wish
is now to you uh literally because of
2020 we've all been living with babadook
and guess what
we've already toppled that because we're
eight months into quarantine and we've
already done this so guess what we
killed it with the power of love threw
some earthworms on it and was like cool
just write another book baba duke
um as for norman bates are you kidding
norman bates versus michael myers
not even michael myers like 2018
halloween
like is at the top of the horror
franchise well even as joel said
uh yeah norman bates the bates motel
underrated i didn't even watch it
because there was no point he's a
regular serial killer on michael myers
is a killing machine
that can actually leave his mama's house
wow okay so michael myers
taking over for norman bates but now we
are going to go to the arguer for norman
bates joel mirrors for his
30-second republic it's all yours i
guess i want to know which michael myers
we're talking about right because don't
they change his story
every other movie like can we not like
retcon it when it gets inconvenient this
is not a scary man
as uh perry said so many sequels so many
sequels
there's a movie in which he changes his
own mask style like three times
this is an inconsistent joke of a
villain really
besides the first movie and us i mean
the true villain of us isn't even the
government don't they actually say in
the film
the real villain is us isn't that what
it's all about uh so i don't even think
that actually qualifies for this round
okay well the government
i don't know if anybody feels weird
heaven to be in a position to go after
defend the government
it's a big day coming up next week for
the government um
eric you have the final say in round
number one 30-second rebuttal and then
i'm gonna kill about 10 seconds and then
we're gonna have our decision so eric
the last sway in round number one is
yours
yeah i mean i hate to offend the ten
people who saw the babadook and the
three people who actually understood the
film
but you know the babadook is it if you
like nuance in your horror movies and
and a lot of you know and horror the
horror of parenting yeah being a parent
is scary
but it's not scarier than having michael
myers and some mask
knock down your door and try to stab you
with some some knife that like that's
a physical scary thing to happen to you
and norman bates is creepy
he's not scary he's not the ultimate
horror villain
he's just like a creepy dude who's like
staying at some like random motel like
if you stop at his motel running that
hotel
that's uh well he's running so he's a
creepy boss of a rider your guy can
drive a car
my guy can run a whole business like
let's
and there's a reason why they've made so
many halloween movies it's because
everybody loves michael myers they want
to continue to see his story play out
uh the halloween movie halloween
challenge halloween
at the end of the day the movie that we
really want to see
is michael myers driving from
haddonfield to california
stopping at bates motel to take a nap
and
what happens that's my question until we
get that answer
i do have a ruling so once again you're
voting with your hearts with that love
button if you think
fandango presents the better argument
you're voting with your thumbs up
that's the like button if you think that
rotten tomatoes did a little bit better
and in round number one taking a lead
before i get to that we have a lot of
fans that are saying hey where was the
likes of
uh where was hannibal lecter that's what
steve tipton wants to know
jeremy nicholas says mickey mouse which
i'm not sure i agree or disagree with
jennifer javon's says one two freddie's
coming for you
and i the hosts of the show say where is
the love
for my boy the leprechaun hopefully he
gets to make it into a later round
in the meantime four passionate
arguments four incredible picks
but team rotten tomatoes gets the point
they got the most amount of votes in
round at number one so rotten tomatoes
gets on the board and goes up one two
nothing which means the team fandango
is now going to be on the clock kicking
off round number two
and in this round it's not going to be a
tag team it's going to be an
individual exercise that's going to see
eric davis
go against perry nemeroff so eric your
argument is going to be first in round
number two which is all about
the best our director
of all time eric davis one minute is
yours
mr wes craven uh he is the best horror
director
uh and he is the most versatile horror
director here's a guy that
created two iconic franchises with
nightmare on elm street and scream
uh equally as iconic villains with
freddy krueger
and ghostface uh equally as iconic
heroines with nancy thompson and sydney
and that's just those two franchises you
also have
uh the hills have eyes the last house on
the left the people under the stairs
even his later stuff like vampire
brooklyn red eye my soul to take
one thing that i love about wes craven
is that he knows
that horror movies could also be playful
he knows that horror movies are a thrill
ride where you should experience all
kinds of different emotions
you know i love how his early work is
super gnarly and crazy and gory
his then his later work is is funny and
irreverent and it looks back on on
itself
and i just love that and also wes craven
was one of the first horror directors to
really weave in social uh
narratives social issues into his movies
um you know like last house on the left
like
uh the people under the stairs for sure
with class inequality
and sexism you know craven was doing
stuff like that jordan peele is doing
now
way back when before audiences were
really prepared to sort of talk and
discuss these
issues and so i think wes craven um you
know
they call him the auntie norman rockwell
uh because he'd always use that american
suburban family to reveal
the horrors of our culture and i think
that all of those reasons
eric's pick wes craven so now one minute
goes to perry and perry i know this is
not fun arguing against your boy
who made scream but you get one minute
so how do you top wes craven
all right i'm focusing on carpenter here
and it feels like
there's no better place to start with
this argument than by pointing out that
rotten tomatoes fans did pick
john carpenter as the winner in uh their
horror director showdown
so i got that working for me and you
guys know how much i love wes craven's
work but when i really thought about an
answer to this question
i really had to go with the person who i
thought was the most influential
horror director and with john carpenter
we're talking about someone with a very
specific
sense of authorship that is very clearly
tied to him and
those qualities one made his movies real
real powerful
and two are things that you can very
clearly spot
in the other films that come after them
and if you want an example of that
just look at the opening scene of
halloween and his use of steadicam there
which
was monumental and it's so
key to how well he establishes geography
and builds tension and so many other
filmmakers use that technique now and
it's a technique that you see in
other masterpieces of his like the thing
halloween the first halloween and the
thing are absolute masterpieces but if
you want to talk about someone with a
really extensive
solid filmography you can just go and
look at what he did
in the fog which is one of his movies
that i think has the most emotional
weight
of the bunch he also tapped into
political satire with they
live look at what he did with christine
it can't be easy to take a killer car
and have that work on screen but he does
and then to top it
all off look at what he's accomplished
as a director but then he is
also one of the best horror composers in
history talk about creating
iconic characters and then also some of
the most iconic scores we have
uh yeah that halloween so i actually got
to see that live i saw john carpenter in
concert and it was
epic and i don't know i see
the biggest scream fan i know perry
arguing for john carpenter i see a guy
with michael myers mask in the
background arguing for wes craven so
worlds are colliding dogs and cats
living together eric
30 seconds for your rebuttal starts
right now
yeah john carpenter is great i love
halloween i think halloween is a
masterpiece but i think if you ask
somebody
about john carpenter most people maybe
saw they saw halloween they saw
the thing and then i don't know after
that by someone and once you get past
those two movies
you know the carpenter stuff that i love
is big trouble in little china escape
from la and new york those aren't really
horror movies but
like those are like my favorite
carpenter movies i think wes craven
you know is just so versatile and i
think and
he's so versatile in that he made all of
these iconic horror movies and then
he created a franchise like scream which
kind of deconstructed the entire genre
and made you look
at horror in a whole new way you know
some stuff that he started to play with
at the end of the nightmare in elm
street
uh with new nightmare you know and so i
think that's really interesting that
he's always had these different takes on
horror movies
he's always made us feel the the run the
gamut of emotions when we're watching
his films
uh and i think even in his later career
carpenter kind of stopped making stuff
uh but craven kept making stuff and he
kept making uh
memorable uh films and eddie murphy and
vampire in brooklyn
um come on which we just talked about on
uh rotten tomatoes is wrong that episode
just dropped actually so you can listen
to
myself jacqueline coley jay washington
talk about
eddie murphy and wes craven and vampire
and broken but for right now
we go back to perinem for her 30-second
rebuttal
scream is my second favorite movie of
all time not horror movie movie of all
time yet i am
fully ready to admit that scream does
not exist without
john carpenter's work in particular
halloween
i am a big fan of craven's work you
can't run through his filmography and
name drop things
like uh my soul to take and have me
believe in your argument whereas
you can look at most of carpenter's
filmography and know that he is at a
certain level if not above the entire
time and when he does stop
directing films he's putting his weight
behind
quality product like that's part of the
reason why the 2018 halloween movie is
one of the best remakes we have because
he supported it and he's also putting a
lot of that work into scoring things
right now i was at that concert with you
mark
carpenter is a person who leans into his
passion and if that's his passion
right now i'm all for it you had to see
people in that audience i think that
that event
is proof that so many out there have
seen the large majority of carpenters
work because no matter the theme that
came on
any of the movies i just named you've
got christine he played you've got music
from the thing he played
all of that everybody lit up in that
crowd everyone knows his work and his
work
always has a certain level of quality if
not higher yeah i didn't want to show
favoritism but yes perry was at that
concert as well it was it was a good
good gang that night but when you're
talking about these arguments it it's so
hard to disseminate and i know firsthand
because on the rotten tomato show versus
they let me have john carpenter versus
wes craven you can catch right now i'm
not going to give away the answer for
who
won that day but in the words of tatum
from scream
we're talking about that wes carpenter
guy and so
we're getting the votes in remember
you're voting with your likes you're
going with that thumbs up if you think
perry uh made the better argument you're
voting with your hearts with your love
but if you think eric made the better
argument
and they're both legendary filmmakers we
would not be having this debate today
if not for wes craven and john carpenter
huge shout out
to wes craven for the comedy that he was
able to put the wink in the nods
in his movies and a big big prop to john
carpenter for getting jon bon jovi
in a vampire movie it's you're gonna
love either one
it doesn't matter who you take and i'm
getting word right now
that okay so let's look at some of these
comments edward harrell
is saying that and night shyamalan is
not getting enough love okay that's a
that's a good take right there we have
i'm seeing a lot of people
say wes craven and then the john
carpenter contingent weighs in as well
so this is this is pretty
david david taylor says carpenter is a
more groundbreaking director than craven
so
it's really tough to go here and the
final
choice now i have confirmation is for
fandango team got the point
and we're all at one to one so eric
davis's director of west craven just
edging out perry and emeroff
with john carpenter so i'm not happy
eric won but i'm happy wes craven one
barry i imagine this is more of a
celebration for you and dewey as well
um we now go to
a third topic that is going to get
heated both
with joel and marquia going at each
other but also in the comments section
so
look we got to put our critical eye on
some things and so this category is all
about
the most overrated horror film
wow this is gonna get good so because
fandango got the point we're gonna kick
off with a minute from
rotten tomatoes editor-in-chief joel
mears joel
one minute is on the clock for your most
overrated
horror film that would be friday
the 13th the original film
uh why when you're thinking about
something that's overrated you have to
establish
in what way it's overrated and friday
the 13th is
always held up as sort of one of the big
three right it's nightmare on elm street
it's halloween
and it's friday the 13th but it doesn't
even begin to belong
in that company and here's why it's
missing three key things that a great
horror movie a great slasher movie and
particularly needs
one is a villain like a decent villain
there's a villain
the mother at the end yeah she like
screams her head off and sort of gets a
bit hysterical and it's a good
performance from betsy page
but the actual villain of that franchise
doesn't even really appear
other than to drown and be a bit useless
so there's no menacing presence
in the film you also need a great
protagonist or final girl
friday the 13th doesn't have that name
her
i'll wait uh it's alice hardy but she's
no sydney prescott i mean she's not even
um
i had to look this up natalie simon from
urban legend
uh she's kind of very subpar there's no
presence there it's also missing
that big thing that you need in a horror
movie which is scariness
this is not a scary film uh it's a it's
a good poster
with a decent soundtrack uh that came
out
and for some reason people liked it
mostly because of the name
okay friday the 13th going all the way
back to ancient christianity for that
sort of cursed
day more on that later or that'll be
after show with bible study but in the
meantime
we go to markeya mccarty for her
one-minute rebuttal marquia
what is the most overrated horror film
of all time
okay well i'm gonna save for mine and
then i'll save my rebuttal for uh the 30
seconds
uh against that blasphemy that was
friday the 13th
uh so what i feel is the
most overrated horror movie of all time
is the blair witch project
uh oh wow wow this movie
okay so uh 1999 and
literally okay one of the things that
people say with the blair witch project
and it's
this so erroneous to assume they're like
oh yeah it
it sparked all of these other movies it
sparked you know
um uh cloverfield you know it sparked uh
paranormal activity
it was not the first um cannibal um
holocaust
actually was the first and it's well
worth a view
what what the blair witch project does
is that it fell within that that
slight niche that was um
the real world and cops were thing and
then there's this 35-page
screenplay that comes along with
improvised dialogue where they shot
eight days in a forest
to make the blair witch project and one
of the only things that it had going for
it was that
people weren't completely sure if it was
authentic or not a lot of people knew it
was but some
didn't so then that's why people kept on
seeing it and the reason why
you know that this is so overrated and
that it should not get
the prestige that it does is the very
fact that
everything after this each of the
sequels
were such flops this this is
not something that should be held up to
the light as a this is a shining example
of what you should do for found footage
i mean if you're if you're going to do
that if you're really going to go down
that found footage hole then
yes paranormal activity would be a
slightly better one to do
found footage in and of itself is there
are times when it gets it right with
like searching
and then there are times when it's just
what
don't mention this movie anymore mention
paranormal activity before you ever
mention
the blair witch project all right the
blair witch project i have strong
feelings on
on both of these and remember you're
voting with your heart if you think
markia has the better movie that's
overrated voting with your thumbs up if
you think joel has a better movie it's
overrated look
we don't get kevin bacon really unless
maybe we had him in friday the 13th but
the marquis point
scarier than the blair witch project was
the mockumentary that sci-fi channel did
three weeks before the blair witch
project came out that made me think this
was real
and i lived in the woods of virginia
right next to maryland i was freaked out
then i saw the movie and i was okay so
joel go back to you
for your 30-second rebuttal starting now
well you brought up the issue of sequels
as being evidence of the first film
maybe not being so great
so i'd have to direct you to every other
movie that jason has appeared in
um so so i would just i would raise that
as one point of order
um the other thing i would say is that
you're looking at two films here
one of them was an innovator whether it
was the absolute first found footage
it was the one that popularized the form
and made it a sensation
and you talk about you know it took what
was happening in the real world and
stuff yeah
like a great horror film it took what
was happening in society
and then it channeled it into something
that really connected with people and
just finally you're looking at an
innovative innovator or an imitator
friday the 13th
is basically a strung together set of
scenes that you've seen before
done much better okay right at the 32nd
ding is joel and yeah neither one of
these
franchises gave us the best sequels of
all time but that's
an argument for another day right now
marquia 30 seconds
in your last salvo here in round number
three
go yes i would love to bring up sequels
like the very fact that sean s
cunningham's uh friday the 13th
then started this friday the 13th
franchise empire that actually toppled
halloween
until it took it back in 2018 so
like those are facts uh along with that
with friday the 13th it
actually instead of just being this
strung together thing that we're going
to do in the in the forest
it set precedent and that's what it was
and it also did social commentary
not only was it a film that was in 1980
it set it back to 1958 to give itself a
foundation to build upon
blair witch project didn't even have
anything like that to build upon in its
shows and its sequels
while with friday the 13th with this
strong foundation where you have pamela
voorhees where you start learning about
the thing with jason voorhees
you know literally this movie is about
having patience to build an
empire which they did and not only that
like
with the social commentary of things
where it's like hey you know what maybe
don't do
sex when you should be watching other
people's kids
[Laughter]
i think that's what friday the 13th did
give the world is such a pure technical
when you're watching someone else's kid
don't don't do sex
yeah put on your own time i think i
think we can all agree on this and i
think even joel even though he's arguing
against marquia can actually ask to hey
kids
don't do sex until november 1st okay
it's a scary time of year
just don't just wait a few days and next
week have a blast and be safe about it
so
um a lot of answers coming in here and
this might be
the question that sparked the most
comments in the two facebook chats
that i'm looking at right now uh eileen
says marquia is speaking truth tameka
also agrees with her about the blair
witch project
um and we're also getting a lot of whose
favorite friday the 13th movies
there are and none of them are the
original friday the 13th which speaks to
joel's point that the sequels although
maybe not beloved ever uh they made a
lot of money and they did at least
eventually give us jason and his hockey
mask
ensemble so uh looking at the comments
here and factoring in
everything about to get a final result
here as to what the most overrated
horror movie is it's between
rotten tomatoes and fandango it's
between friday the 13th
the original one and the blair witch
project
the original one and the winner is
final confirmation says fandango goes up
two to one marquia here we go
gotten her team a lead 2-1 just over
joel
joel maybe it was my comment about how
much people love kevin i didn't mean to
sabotage you there
so now ah yeah well congratulations i
thought you did a a wonderful job for
a great film and
getting a lot of people uh interested
well
we'll talk about that after well i think
a fun double feature might be cannibal
holocaust and then go
up against blair witch project but we
are now going to talk about
the scariest double feature you could
ever possibly have and for everybody
keeping score at home
no no one has mentioned my boy the
leprechaun yet
will he pop up in the scariest double
feature argument
well we are about to find out so this is
going to be another tag team event
where everybody's going to get to weigh
in on what the scariest double feature
of all time
is and to kick us off because fandango
just got a point we're going to start
with rotten tomatoes
so perry joel who wants to kick off with
their minute argument for scariest
double feature
you let me choose last time now you
choose yeah i'll i'll let you go my
mouth's a little dry from all that heat
all right i got this joel needs to uh
chill in the corner for a little bit
because he just gave a passion argument
against friday
the 13th so now perry nemeroff for one
minute on the clock
the scariest double feature round four
kicks off
right now right now i am arguing
for sinister and the shining for for
sinister
not many movies keep me up at night
anymore
but this one most certainly did
first the movies within the movie are
some of the most
brutal sequences and disturbing imagery
i think i've ever seen in my life but
then
on top of that you got scott derekson
and c robert cargill
connecting all of that together
especially well
through the fret the threat of bagool
which is
hands down one of the scariest
characters out there
i mean really can some of you out there
honestly tell me after seeing sinister
for the first time you didn't go home
and google
is bagool from sinister real seriously
go and google it
and just type in like the first like
couple of letters and i guarantee you it
will autofill that
but in the mythology of the movie here
they say that it's believed that images
of bagols
serve as a gateway for him to come into
the mortal world and i got a super cool
poster from the movie sinister that i
wanted to hang up on my wall so badly
and i actually thought twice before i
hung it on my wall
so that just speaks to how creepy that
is and
the shining the shining is one of the
most iconic genre movies of
all time and the the idea of going to
a location like that being completely
snowed in
with someone that you're related to your
father or your husband that's
deteriorating that's losing his mind and
has no control over what's going to
happen to him
that is one of the most terrifying
things ever and
speaking oh i wanted to talk about the
imagery
i mean look you get the the coolest maze
maybe in movie history well i guess
labyrinth is probably the coolest maze
but the shining is probably top five
so now we pivot over to team fandango
it's eric
and marquia uh eric marquia do you have
any thoughts on who you'd like to go
first in round number four
marquis i always defer to you i always
defer to you
oh sweet oh well i i just did a lot of
talking how about you get your stuff in
madoo
okay i think eric with really good
advice for all my major decisions i also
go to marquia
who just scored a point on behalf of
fandango now eric davis steps up to the
fandango plate minute on the clock
and eric scariest double feature all
right well when i think of like the
ultimate horror movie i think of
of the four pillars of of what makes a
movie scary
it's got to have a memorable villain
it's gotta have a memorable
hero or heroine it's gotta have
memorable music and it has to have a
premise that scares you
to your core uh and so for me i go
halloween
and i'm gonna double up with the the
recent version of halloween because they
kind of follow each other
and the reason why i think halloween has
everything
it has your memorable pavilion it's got
michael myers
it's got your the most memorable heroine
of all time and lori strode
it's got that music that you can't get
out of your head the music
is a character in and of itself uh and
it's got a premise that just scares you
to your core or just a masked stranger
roaming around your small town
neighborhood and i think that
the you know 1978 original halloween but
then you have all
the way to 2018 uh and
all of these years and still the same
story uh they
they evolved it they they took lori
strode and they they created a new
version of that character
uh and spoke to themes of trauma uh and
and how you overcome that
uh when you have a family and you're
trying to keep them together and i
thought that
you know for a film that followed so
many years later i
i just thought the two of them are
really great to pair together
um and to and i think that it's the
ultimate
horror movie and the scariest in my
opinion
okay eric davis minute is
done so now eric uh we're gonna go from
you
with uh putting all your eggs in the
proverbial halloween
trick-or-treat bag we're gonna pivot
back over to joel joel if you got a sip
of water
and you're ready to get going then it is
now one minute
to you for your scariest
double feature
and joel has left the building ladies
and gentlemen so
joel has we scared the editor-in-chief
of rotten tomatoes
to the point where he had to take five
and get the hell out of that look i
understand it we're talking about a lot
of scary stuff right now
maybe joel was thinking back to his days
camping in australia
maybe he was thinking about going door
to door and trick-or-treating
but regardless of that while we wait for
joel to get back markia
i hate to put you on the spot right now
but to keep a smooth show flowing
do you feel ready to step up with your
one minute scary double feature
oh yeah yeah yeah definitely definitely
all right then ladies and gentlemen you
know what marquee i'm going to give you
65 seconds
starting now uh yeah uh
ultimate double feature that should be a
part of everybody's horror watch um
every halloween is uh definitely
halloween
and nightmare on elm street the original
i
can't okay because i literally i i
watched a lot of horror movies
and i literally tried to think oh what
would be something fun you know
like to be able to say with this and
it's like no it always comes back to
nightmare on l street elm street
what wes craven did with freddy krueger
the
multiple layers that you have with that
are so incredible not
only do you have um not only do you have
kids that have to take on the sins of
the parents
not only do you have that not only do
you have the layers of murder
justifiable murder and vengeful spirits
coming back
you have freddy krueger coming in
as this oh it's like this mythic beast
that you
cannot fall asleep the one thing that we
allow ourselves as humans when we're not
dealing with insomnia
it's like you can't do that and and put
that together
with everything that wes craven did with
that everything from the steak knives
into the gloves to like hooking
his actor up to a car battery just so
like things can spark
to tina gray's iconic killing
where she's flopping on the walls and
then falling dead on the bed i mean
all of this it stands the test of time
just like halloween and then yes
like what eric was saying with halloween
2018 stan
test of time these are iconic decades
worthy of poor that are on this like
very
very stable foundation when i think
sinister
i i'm like hey you know this is really
cool but i wish the hero wasn't so
dumb you know in that i mean nancy
thompson
was smart and she did what she could
what she had to do freddie keeps on
coming but and then also with sinister
she's like
just too many jump scares okay rain lash
windows it's like i've seen i've seen
these before
and i've seen these done better i
appreciate having them all in one movie
but it's standing on the shoulders of
giants and then with the shining what
shining are we talking about
i assume the original all right that's
65 seconds and
perry were both so excited to talk about
the shining for very different reasons
but they got so excited about the other
movie so marquia giving us a little
carpenter craven
harkening back to a previous round so
joel we're getting word that you are now
back in the ring
um can you confirm was it either a black
cat that ran right in front of you
was it something going bump in the
closet what scared you so much that you
had to take five
it was sinister the the a perfect film
to watch with the shining of course
uh no i was getting some unfriended
action over here i think on my screen
um so uh yeah it was i apologize that
was not an attempt to psych people out
that is just the terrible internet
connection on the upper west side of
manhattan today
so i apologize uh so i'm going to talk
about the shining right
uh you joel are here to talk about your
scariest double feature
so whatever the double feature is and
hopefully within the next minute amazon
will not come back to the door for
another package
so i'm team rotten tomatoes and i do
think a perfect horror double feature
is the shining and sinister and there's
two reasons why
i'll get to the shining in a second but
you want your old and you're new you
want your foundational you want your
classic you want your groundbreaking you
want probably the greatest film ever
made let alone the greatest horror film
ever made
um and then you want something new you
want to see where the genre has actually
come
to you want something fresh to see where
it's progressed and something that's
actually truly terrifying there was
actually a study released this week
where sinister
they they hooked people's uh arms up to
see their blood pressure
uh during watching films during watching
uh horror films and sinister was by far
the movie that raised people's blood
pressure more than any other
i could be making it up fake news who
knows but i'm not it was in a press
release it came into my inbox
but the shining is literally the meeting
of two of the greatest creative minds
ever to walk the earth you've got
stanley kubrick
possibly the greatest filmmaker ever
born and stephen king
they were not necessarily a marriage
made in heaven in terms of it being
sort of pleasant but what they produced
was
a landmark film it's not just uh
phenomenal in all the ways that you know
we can go on about but it's actually the
best of multiple horror subgenres
so you think about it the last stretch
of the shining is like the best slasher
movie ever made right
the entire film is the greatest
psychological thriller ever produced
there's even great zombie moments and
it's clearly the best haunted
hotel slash house slash apartment with
bad wi-fi movie you could possibly
conjure
at the center of it it's also got
groundbreaking extraordinary
performances not just from jack
but from scat man crothers from shelley
duvall
and uh from denny lloyd it i'm talking
about the original
the original i'm not talking about the
mini series i'm not talking about dr
sleep
that's that's your minute joel uh that
was great and we actually got some love
in the shining there and
to joel's point i'll help him clarify
we're not talking about that tv
miniseries with stephen weber from the
hit sitcom wings
we're talking about the original shining
from stanley kubrick's genius mind
based off of stephen king's genius novel
so
all right folks it's down to the 30
minute rebuttal round each competitor is
gonna get 30 seconds to talk about why
their double feature is the scariest and
after that
we're going to sort out based on your
votes so if you think team rotten
tomatoes
is making the better argument that would
be perry and joel then you're going to
be clicking that thumbs up
the like button if you think that markia
and eric team fandango
have what it takes to scare you the most
then you're going to be clicking the
heart
the love button so perry we go
back to you for 30 seconds you may rebut
however you like talk more about your
movies
talk some junk against what marquia and
eric are putting out there the 30
seconds is all yours
starting now i think we're losing focus
here that this double feature
is for the ultimate scary movies you
can't really include
nightmare on elm street and that because
those movies aren't scary
the concept is scary and then that
franchise turned into a horror comedy
franchise so that is out of here
entirely
and the sad truth about halloween is
nowadays if you want to recommend a
double feature to younger moviegoers out
there
that movie is gonna feel slow and it's
gonna drag
whereas the pacing in something like the
shining
still is just sky high and it sucks you
into that hotel in a heartbeat and going
back to the imagery i was trying to
point out before
those visuals are seared into my brain
from seeing it as a kid
and that's a movie that stands the test
of time holds up especially well now to
this day
okay perry convincing argument the
concept of freddy krueger pretty
horrifying
and that's also for me being a comedian
because of all the scary horror movie
villains he's the one i would least like
to follow on stage because freddie
is hilarious but that's a point for
another round in the meantime
we pivot to eric davis for his 30-second
rebuttal eric you got 30 seconds on the
clock
beginning now
and eric i think you might have muted
yourself we're gonna
it's actually this feels okay because
joel had to take five and now eric is
going to take five for some tech stuff
so
marquia i hate to once again put you
into the ring
when you're not fully prepared and ready
to go but you did great last time
so 30 seconds are now going to be yours
if you're ready
yeah yeah yeah let's do it all right
let's do it you're on the clock starting
now
uh perry i'm saddened and disheartened
that you don't feel like today's horror
uh watchers can appreciate these
foundations that everything is built on
like the the and iconic moments and
nightmare on elm street
yes made in 1984 holding up today i'm
talking uh glenn's death
where uh freddy krueger's uh talons well
we'll call him talons
like come through the bed when he's just
fallen to sleep
and like just talking about the bedroom
wall talking about the weapon
construction
with this you're talking about a society
that still embraces doctor who
embraces classic doctor who and now
because we love
seeing where it comes from we love
seeing how it is and we love
seeing the things that uh other people
you know standing on the shoulders of
giants as far as the shiny is stephen
king hates the shining so i just needed
to say that joel
he that's like his one of his top things
that he hates it that was made
yes i it's it's a very good film but for
like a dual feature for
halloween you do halloween and you do
nightmare on elm street
because that's where you start and then
you do all the other things that stood
on the shoulders of these giants
okay so a very convincing argument and
yes stephen king
not a fan of stanley kubrick's picture
for whatever reasons
he may have had uh before we go to maybe
joel i just want to check in with eric
eric how was your audio situation is
there still a ghost in the machine
starring ice cube i believe
there is still a ghost in eric's machine
eric you better look out there might be
a creature named larry from a movie
that has just been released in theaters
and soon to be on fandango now right
behind your computer so
while eric works on his technical
difficulties marquis is doing a
fantastic job at carrying the squad
but now we're gonna go back to joel for
his thirty second rebuttal switzerland
this is the last chance
the team rotten tomatoes is gonna get to
stump for their double feature
and that 30 seconds for you starts right
now
pressure pressure pressure what they're
recommending is a film
class they want you to have a night
where you're studying not when you're
scared
they're saying go back and study the
films the shoulders etc we're trying to
give you a night where you get
shaken and where you're entertained and
you want to talk about iconic images a
couple of blood on the wall and the glen
getting in the bed
i raise you an elevator full of blood
red rum
give me the bat all work and no play
makes a doll boy
here's johnny the maze i could go on but
i'm actually gonna stop
okay um i'm seeing so many great uh
gifts on both chats right now i'm seeing
a lot of freddie
i'm seeing a lot of michael and that
jack torrance one of him just given that
classic jack nicholson smile so
uh eric how's your how's your audio
situation
okay we're still getting nothing but
apologies from eric but that's okay
because you know what eric
michael myers was a man of few words as
well but he certainly made his point
over a variety of movies so if eric
can't do the 30 seconds then
marquia guess who gets to step back into
the spotlight for 30 more seconds
it is all yours markia mccarty for eric
davis
starting right now okay uh
a number of uh really amazing reasons
why
halloween should definitely be part of
your double feature with nightmare on
elm street which is already there
because that's
that's one of those things that just say
with with halloween yes we're talking
about foundations but this isn't a film
studies class how
weird to say that this this is part of
our history this is our
horror zeitgeist that's what this is uh
with with halloween you have uh
mike mike myers and it's not just a
a dumb stalker or someone who's like
like
from norman bates hotel or something
like that this
this is someone that had to happen for
everything else to happen
like this is what we were talking about
before with john carpenter's halloween
you get that
plus you get wes craven this is what
this entire argument has been based upon
when it's wes craven versus john
carpenter but you get both
i'm sorry wait yes um oh wait wait
you're back eric
oh ladies and gentlemen eric davis
coming back
thank you
seconds uh and so the two combined yeah
i
i do i give them credit for that uh but
you know when you have halloween and you
have nightmare and elmshore
i mean there are there are no two more
iconic villains in horror movies and so
i think that's why we definitely deserve
eric jumping in
i i it's good eric when you finally got
your audio back but uh
that was a great teamwork that was the
most seamless
handing off of a baton that i've seen
since the last time we got to witness
the summer olympics and
so these are two great double features i
encourage everybody watching right now
to
immerse yourself whether you want to
call it a film class or just a scary
movie night
check all these flicks out because those
were two impassioned arguments for
four of the greatest scary movies of all
time but there can only be one winner
and that winner may be determined for
binge battle halloween edition
right now as we tabulate the final votes
we have a lot of comments pouring in so
much to sort out and get to
ladies and gentlemen i have the final
results of this round
marquia mccarty did a stellar job both
with her own time
and getting eric's time while eric was
uh shall we say indisposed
but it was not enough to topple the
rotten tomatoes squad and we are
tied at two apiece and you know what
that means
it is time for the tie breaker round you
wouldn't want it any other way
it's halloween remember when you're a
kid and you're trick-or-treating or
you're an adult
like me last year and you still try to
go trick-or-treating and you said come
on mom come on dad
three more houses let me go get a little
bit more candy we have extra candy for
everybody watching right now
and that is our sudden death debate
question here's how it's gonna work so
every competitor
is gonna get one minute and that's it
you get one minute and then you're done
with your argument and you're going to
be arguing
for the scariest moment
in movie history what is the most
frightening moment
you've ever seen in a horror movie
god i love questions like this and i
love that i just get to host and i don't
have to actually think
about all the times that i've been kept
up late at night by something i saw on a
movie
screen and not been able to sleep so
instead that honor
is gonna go first to team fandango who's
looking to get that winning point
eric marquia i maybe we should go ahead
and have eric
give his one minute first just to be
safe with his audio
just so eric you're gonna get 60 seconds
starting right now for your most
frightening moment go
i'm going back to the classic i'm going
to stephen spielberg's
jaws and the moment that i'm going to in
jaws
is uh a classic moment you know one
thing that spielberg does
with jaws is and i talk about those four
pillars
you know your your villain your hero
your premise
and your music and the music in jaws
spielberg uses it
to cue you to say okay every time i hear
that done done done the shark's gonna be
there
but then towards the end of the film you
know brody's throwing throwing the bait
into the water and then all of a sudden
the shark
jumps out at the water and it freaks him
out it throws him back
it's the the closest uh that we've seen
the shark to date
he doesn't use the music so where the
audience isn't expecting it at all
and then as he gets jolted back he
delivers one of the most iconic lines
in in not just in horror history but in
movie history
you know you're gonna need a bigger boat
uh and so that moment i think has
the entire recipe of a moment because
spielberg builds to it the entire
film you don't even know he's building
to it and then all of a sudden
the shark shows up we haven't seen the
shark this close up yet
it's the scariest thing people didn't go
into the water
for years i still don't go into the
water because of that film
haven't been in the water since i was a
kid uh because of jaws
because that moment was the scariest
moment in horror history
okay wait before we let you go eric so
let me clarify so you didn't eat after
midnight but you didn't worry about
getting wet
when you were a kid on your gremlins
fear
i was i was always worried i stopped
eating after midnight
i stopped going into the beach uh
because of these
these choices that's why mark they're so
scary to me
and to everybody else out there too okay
i think the next time eric does a shot
on good morning america
we we get wet and we feed him after
midnight and we expose something we just
if we turn my microphone off no it
could be the case so we have the jaws
classic scene that i love watching every
fourth of july
and now we pivot over to rotten tomatoes
so joel perry
any uh inklings as to who wants to go
first with their scariest moment in
movie history
what you think uh i can go if you like
and then uh
i'll let you i'll let you finish it off
because i think you're gonna finish
strong i like your choice
all right okay second starting
now so my choice is not unlike eric's in
that it is a monster reveal in some ways
but unlike his it's not just a comedic
punchline
the descent is actually one of the most
terrifying movies
ever made and i'm putting myself at a
slightly disadvantage here because it's
maybe a movie that not everyone has seen
but it's from 2005 and it's essentially
about a group of women who go
cave dwight cave diving um slowly they
get trapped
issues come up from their past and there
are hints all throughout there might be
something else
in this cave and there is this
incredible moment where they're having
just sort of everything's coming to a
boil it's 55 minutes in
all of the tensions and fighting it's
been happening they put on the night
vision cam
there's they're swirling around it's
complete chaos
and then bam behind one of the women is
this humanoid monster
and it is literally the scariest moment
i've ever experienced in
a theater and i was an adult so if you
want to go with something that scares
children
and that's really more memorable for the
laugh line that comes after
go for jaws but if you want to go for
something that's genuinely scary
and new and fresh the descent is the
moment you'd be looking for
all right the descent joel getting me
inspired to go watch that movie
again and taking on eric davis with his
jaws moment so now we're going to pivot
back to marquia so marquia
we have two pretty great moments already
with jaws
and the descent and i cannot wait for
you to add to the party
with your 60 seconds starting right now
i will say that the world is 71 water
and 97 of that water is salt water so
that's a whole lot of water for jaws
to live in to come get you um but for my
moment
it is it follows uh so 2014 if you have
not seen it and mine in particular is
when
uh the whole thing with uh it follows is
that it's it's a demon
an entity that is transmitted through a
sexual contact
it will follow you no matter what we
have our group of uh
survivors or they think that they are um
chilling on the beach
and then as they're sitting there it
comes
walking up one of the things with it is
that it will always disguise itself in a
way so that it can get
close to you and it is disguised the
person that it is following is jay
height
and she does not see it you literally
see in this scene the scene of what she
would see if she looked over her if she
looked over her shoulder but you also
see
what everybody else sees because they
cannot see it so literally her hair just
stands up on end
and they try to attack it they cannot
they run from it
it chases them into like this beach
house where it like goes through a wall
and one of the chilling statements that
they say when it
you know bursts itself into the wall
they look at her and they're like what
is it that you see
what do you see because they cannot see
it it keeps on changing its form
to keep on messing with her and she runs
you cannot sleep you cannot rest it will
always follow and that scene on that
beat
gets me in ways that i cannot even
like totally articulate right now it's
like not only the do you have to trust
who you sleep with and everybody else
that they slept with before
but it's also that it will never stop
and it will always come yeah that's uh
what i was saying to kids about just
waiting until november 1st you may just
want to watch it follow us and just
never worry about it
just just enter the priesthood or be a
nun it's not worth it trust me
if you see it follows you're going to
feel the same way that marquia does
especially that scene i found myself
just focusing because we were running
that scene as you were talking about
it and i was just like i forgot how good
this scene is so that is a
great entry into the most frightening
moment in movie history
and now perry nemeroff steps up to the
plate
she adjusts the batting gloves she gets
into the batter's box
for 60 seconds your scariest moment
in movie history perry keep in mind
we're arguing for the most frightening
moment
an iconic line of dialogue does not make
that the most frightening moment and
then on top of that that it follow
scenes is a well executed sequence that
has a slow burn effect to it that's not
frightening
what joel said about the descent that is
a jump scare
that doesn't leave you and an image of a
creature that doesn't leave you
i am adding the ending of paranormal
activity to this list right now
that in addition to sinister is one of
the only modern horror movies that have
kept me up at night and i think it's
loaded with fantastically shot and
creative scares but that ending
is next level because you care about
katie and micah so much and because the
way they shoot that movie works so well
you have a one two three punch in
katie's blood curdling scream which i
will never be able to unhear
micah being viciously thrown at the
camera and then if that's not enough for
you
katie then creeps close to the camera
and reveals her demon face after all
that i
guarantee you you have seen that imagery
pop up all over the place
it was also hands down one of my best in
theater experiences ever
when that last sequence played and in
particular when katie went demon
my entire theater erupted one of the
best communal
viewing experiences i ever had and that
right there signals
it is the most frightening moment all
right
four great arguments for four of the
most frightening moments in
movie history and it's times like these
when i'm so happy that i am simply just
here pounding the gap
we have a jury of amazing
fans and commenters out there watching
on either facebook platform you could be
watching on fandango rotten tomatoes and
if you're joining us via youtube
thank you everybody checking us out on
movie clips by the way fun facts so for
the best
hard director argument apparently a lot
of folks
on youtube watching us buying movie
clips were saying james wan is the guy
why is nobody
saying james juan so certainly a lot of
votes for mr juan on youtube but right
now we're relying on
facebook likes and facebook loves to get
those results for who wins
the tie breaking round get those last
votes in if it's team rotten tomatoes
that you favor
if you think that perry and joel are
correct with either
the descent or if you're talking about
perry's argument of paranormal activity
you're going to click that thumbs up
you're going to click that like button
if you think that eric and marquia
had the stronger scariest moments it
follows and jaws
you're gonna hit that love button that's
the heart and as we wait for our final
tally to come
in it's about ready and i can declare
that nobody wants to talk about the
leprechaun not even as the funniest
horror movie villain
who's funnier let's go around the horn
really quick who's funnier
is it the leprechaun or is it freddy
chucky that might be the right answer
what is your favorite leprechaun moment
my favorite leprechaun moment
it's got to be in leprechaun 4 when
leprechaun in it so he was in the hood
and then he went to outer space
and in outer space there's a scene not
only is there a great star wars
reference there's also a scene
where somehow the leprechaun can travel
via
um somebody relieving themselves into
somebody else's body you can yes folks
i'm not making this up if you go in
outer space
apparently you can pee on someone and
that's how leprechaun got into somebody
else and can possess people so
leprechaun has a lot of tools
in his magical irish belt and so all i'm
saying is that i know you want to hang
out with him keeping it armed
keep him in on your tv you don't want to
hang out with leprechaun in day to day
life maybe he's got a pot of gold
it's probably just that cheap chocolate
that's in the tin foil that's not real
gold
anyway i digress i was hoping to get
more leprechaun love but
wow you all did a great job fandango and
ron tomatoes teaming up and then going
at one another
to give us maybe the most thrilling and
certainly scariest binge battle we've
ever had
and it is now my honor to declare the
winner of the halloween edition of binge
battle
favoring markia mccarty and eric davis
they got the win for the scariest moment
maybe it was it follows maybe it's jaws
but
marquee and eric between your two movie
most frightening moments
you're basically telling folks hey you
can never go in the water again and you
can never sleep with anyone again so
what
is there to do what's more frightening
than that that's what i'm saying it's
you can't have sex you can't go in the
water you can't go to the beach you
can't do anything
yeah i just want people to know i'm
extremely sex positive by the way so
that's why
these moments are very terrifying for me
well it is a huge win for team fandango
i want to
thank team rotten tomatoes for sterling
arguments
in each and every round and before we
get out of here
i do want to make sure everybody out
there watching right now can figure out
where they can follow you all because
i'm sure they love your personalities
and they want to get to know you a
little bit better
so not in it it follows kind of way but
perry where can everybody on social
media
check you out we'll start with you i am
on twitter and instagram at penameroff
and give our best to deputy dewey the
adorable kitty
uh joel mears where can uh all the gang
check you out
uh just on twitter at joel mears and
congratulations guys you really did uh
put up a great well you put up a great
fight you smashed us so well done
and eric davis working with kids check
out your stuff uh you could follow me on
twitter as well
at eric with the k davis and uh i would
also like to say that i think
joel and perry are two of the biggest
horror aficionados that i know and so
to defeat them uh is something that
robert
is gonna have to this goes on the resume
has to go on the resume to defeat them
to beat them it should make you feel
good joel and perry that you know eric
and marquia are
are bowing to worthy competitors uh
marquia where can everybody find you and
your very scary twitter handle
uh yeah you can find me on twitter and
instagram at marquia mccarty and the way
that you spell it is probably below me
somewhere
uh and then if you're really into like
horror and like spooky seasoned stuff
check out youtube.com snarled we do
animated horror episodes uh
every week and i i just uh and i do
and where podcasts are found look for
something scary the something scary
podcast because i narrate more
i do want to say um yeah no i
all of this just revitalizes the love of
horror
i mean it's not just october horror is
life as we've
said with all the different arguments
that we've had with this and how it's
like
social commentary along with jump scares
and like all these levels i've
thoroughly enjoyed this like so much
thank you all of you
for like this bit of joy in 2020. so
much fun to yes have that that brief
moment of uh
escapism and uh and fun and i want to
thank everybody
behind the scenes of both rotten
tomatoes and fandango for making this
engine go it takes a lot of moving parts
to make this production so smooth
they make my job very easy so thank you
to our incredible
hard-working tech team and everybody
voting thank you everybody i hope you
continue that voting trend into next
week
and we loved having you share your
thoughts on some of the scariest moments
it's directors uh creators franchises in
movie history before we let you go
i will remind everybody check out
rottentomatoes.com that's a great hub
for a lot of stuff going on streaming
right now
fandango now has a lot of great options
for your scary movie cravings that are
going to be going on this weekend and
you can check out the rotten tomatoes is
wrong podcast hosted by jacqueline coley
and some idiot that's talking right now
we're talking about some scary movies we
had hocus pocus
we had vampire in brooklyn and it's i
can't give away what next week's episode
is just yet
but you're going to want to listen so on
behalf of the incredible panelists the
hard-working team and all you fans out
there watching movie clips fandango
rotten tomatoes i am merely mark ellis
have a great halloween stay safe out
there watch out for kids
and enjoy your candy you've earned it
[Music]
you